the political crisis in Hong Kong is
spiraling over fears of Chinese control
even after a controversial extradition
bill was scrapped nearly two million
people flooded Hong Kong streets
yesterday
ramie Inocencio is in Hong Kong ramie it
seems a protesters won this round so why
are they still out there
good morning it depends on what time
frame you're looking at they seem to
have won the short-term battle but
there's a fear they're losing the long
term war based on an agreement signed in
the 1980s this former British colony
will revert to total Chinese control in
the year 2040 seven Hong Kongers hit the
streets with mass fury Sunday demanding
their government revoke a hated
extradition law that could send them to
mainland China's subjective legal system
and calling for the resignation of their
chief executive Kerry lamb appointed by
Beijing after sunset Kerry Lama did
apologize but only on paper it's now
eight hours into this rally and you can
see people are still on the streets with
cell phone lights shining the way this
was very much a 21st century protest
spurred by recent violent clashes where
dozens of protesters and police were
hurt and the first casualty when this
protester fell to his death Saturday
opposition legislator Lee Shahan says
Beijing's image has fractured now they
have losing control in Hong Kong and
they have the retreat so it showed that
there's a weakness on a part of the
Chinese regime but mainland Chinese
citizens never saw at the start of
Sunday's protests chinese state media
had a special report on blood supply
while foreign media in the country went
black
thanks to China's censors
back here in Hong Kong the government
and the opposition are trying to figure
out what to do next and just hours ago
Beijing reiterated its support for
Carrie Lam it seems she's not going
anywhere for now
Anthony Amy innocencio in Hong Kong I
like you can't underlined enough how
huge the rally was there was like 2
million people million people out of
seven million people who live in the
territory and the entire population
third yeah that's an extraordinary
number this idea of one country China
and Hong Kong but two systems doesn't
seem like it's gonna hold forever well
it's supposed to it's got another 30
years but there's obviously already a
flashpoint here